foreign
[Music]
collectively are the also the filmmakers
of searching the movie that came out in
2018 with John Cho
um and I did a q a I believe with you
and a niche and John Cho for for
searching because John was nominated for
best actor for searching this time
around
you did a little Switcheroo though
so can you explain
um how you changed roles because you all
worked on searching but now you're are
you all in different roles now on
missing I kind of okay we call it
musical chairs basically we just waited
for the music to stop and whoever got
whatever jobs oh you're the producer
this time you're the director no all
jokes aside um on searching uh Anish
chaganti and I co-wrote the screenplay
and then Anish directed and then Natalie
and I produced Nick and will were the
editors and we had such a good time
making that movie has anyone here seen
searching
amazing and everyone else you guys are
gonna go rent it tonight awesome so
basically we made searching on a very
tiny budget even smaller than this and
uh we spent two years editing it in like
a tiny room like five people sharing
essentially a shed and uh we had such a
good time and and when the studio asked
us to make a second movie a niche was
never going to direct it oh by the way
guys this is Will Merrick co-director
co-writer
um we knew that Anish would not want to
direct another movie on a computer
screen it seems like every director has
maybe one computer screen in them and
that's it but luckily we didn't have to
look far for it to find the the writers
and directors because it was Will and
Nick it was always going to be willing
Nick for us so that's an interesting
statement every director only has one
computer screen movie
do you want to talk about why that is
why is it difficult to direct a computer
screen movie I think I think these guys
should talk about it for sure
everybody know what the premise the
filmmaking premise of these movies is
can you just sort of lay out because
it's
you don't we don't see anything that
doesn't happen through an electronic
device right yeah that I would say
that's more or less
um that's that's correct yeah the way
that we conceptualize it is anything
with a screen is fair game but I think
it's the fun of making making a movie
like this and also the uh the
challenging aspect is is holding
yourself to strict rules
um so it can be frequently I think to
answer your question about why just one
screen movie yeah as you're making a
movie
um you know you have this great plot
point or this idea and then you're like
oh God damn it how are we watching this
though how are we seeing this this is
this constant
um struggle but I also think that when
you do find it and in some cases maybe
the answer is oh actually we don't need
to see it actually maybe we can just
accomplish this with a mouse
um you know so I think that's also the
fun of it
um but yeah that's that's why I do too
because I remember when I was watching
the first one and they suggest that
you're going to go to a location that's
outdoors and I'm like they're not gonna
be able to do that it's outside it but
of course you know there was a device
that explained how they could shoot
something outside and he's shotgun T
producer welcome hello
so um when
how soon after
um searching did you start thinking
about doing missing
we got the call six months after the
movie had come out and like just laid
out searching one cost eight hundred and
eighty thousand dollars and it made 75
million dollars in theaters alone which
is nuts
um so Sony naturally was under a million
dollar budget yeah that's crazy and made
totally independent crazy
sorry and made independently so we we
made it you know with no Studio attached
no distribution and then we got into
Sundance which was like a dream come
true for all of us and Sony acquired the
movie there
I just saw Sadie I love Sadie she was in
our short film that was uh like
something that we did in preparation for
this movie so I'm sorry I thought there
was like a drama in fullness you were
like and she like rolled her eyes and I
was like oh my God what's going on
um reading all the non-verbals you guys
um so uh how did you uh conceive of the
story of this and um
yeah what what inspired this the story
for missing
so seven Anish wrote the the treatment
so do you guys want to speak on just the
ideation process there
uh yeah I mean after
you know as Sony started approaching us
and
um for a while we said no we're there's
no way we're ever going to make a sequel
to a computer screen movie that's stupid
um and eventually you know
some years had passed and at one point
and Sev pitched the idea of what if we
just reversed the um uh essentially the
characters in the movie instead of
having a father look for a a daughter
have a child look for a parent and it
suddenly felt like that gave a lot of
like
energy into the movie a totally
different POV on the internet which we
realized like was a different place four
years ago when searching came out you
know like when we made that movie it
felt like a sequel would be just taking
place in the same world but in reality
four years changes the way we interact
online and adds new apps and services
and everything changes so suddenly we
felt like we had a space to be creative
and and he came up with this idea we
flushed it out over 18 Pages gave it to
Willa Nick and said there are 18 pages
of problems in here fix them and uh they
did
and then how long did it take you to fix
18 pages of problems they're also really
good things in there I have to admit but
there were some pretty good things there
was the live photo reveal yeah that's it
that's that's it no the the entire story
sorry what was the original questions
just how the story came out how long
yeah
man I mean the entire two years of
working on the movie really
I mean we we brought our editors on a
month uh a half before production even
began and we uh worked on like a
previous with them that was kind of the
final rewrite of the movie leading into
production so I yeah the team just kind
of grew and we just kept working on the
story with a with a big team
so talk about working on your actors
on this
in particular
um your lead who's absolutely amazing
uh so I guess first question is how did
you choose your lead
um why did you know that you wanted to
work with her
yeah I mean uh invisible man came out
not long before uh this movie and storm
was in that in in you know kind of kind
of a mid-level role I guess and showed
so much emotion she was so good and then
um I mean you know pretty quickly we
knew we wanted to talk to her but as
soon as uh she she agreed to read which
is kind of rare I think on you know a
movie like this and and you know frankly
like she's already kind of a star before
this movie
um and she was so emotional it was
insane she just turned it on and
immediately was just so emotional there
was just no discussion after that right
yeah
so the film like this you really kind of
need actors who can work really well
with just their face right and their
voice
how do you how do you help an actor
through this because I remember when
John Cho was with us on that interview
it was kind of like what are you saying
and he was like you mean the post didn't
know if that was taped it was green so
because none of the visual is are any of
the visuals ready for her yet to see for
her to see what the audience will be
seeing later on
no so like will said Wiggy um had done
previz for like 25 27 weeks or something
so we had a fully fleshed out watchable
movie at that point but we didn't first
of all it was just me and will like
screenshots like terrible acting of me
and will like performing the whole movie
so we didn't we we weren't particularly
keen on the actors watching that or um
you know uh so but it was like a road
map for us right so what what storm was
looking at would have been just like a
gray screen and then we had little like
computer folders that we'd label
FaceTime uh notification
um you know uh Post-it sticky here and
so like actors generally you know
um one of the most incredible things
that actors do is hit these very
technical you know blocking
um things in a scene while also staying
present somehow and and um and uh her
challenge was to do that but like almost
eye line blocking right and remember
these really technical things
um so everything she was seeing was
completely imagined and in her head
um and I have a you know we all have
huge respect for her uh to do that she
had never done anything like that um
yeah you know it started her eye line
started as uh I don't I don't think I
can get this microphone to work
um her eye line thing started as a grid
of numbers uh on a computer screen and
then pretty quickly we found out it's
easier to just create folders on the
desktop and name them the story beat and
put them where they need to be foreign
cool
um so is there is there anything in this
film I
I forgot when I was watching this film I
remembered from watching the first one
that I love the ASMR in this film I love
the keyboard clocks of a laptop and
um the clicks like I've met it's kind of
soothing so even though you're watching
a thriller
it's like those little it reminds me of
like from the game mist
it's kind of meditative anyway like the
CL I don't know does anybody else feel
that it has great ASMR we'll send you
the stem of the film
thank you I'll just play it to go to
sleep
um is there anything that the characters
can do with technology in this film that
they couldn't have done in the 2018 film
or did you set that as a challenge for
yourself like let's have them do
something they couldn't have done in the
last
film I have a feeling yeah you guys have
his answer I was gonna say well if you
took David Kim who was who's a boomer
dad and put him in missing he he would
really struggle because like he wouldn't
be able to navigate everything that June
does with so much like dexterity
um but yeah there's a lot of absent you
know Tick Tock wasn't a thing
um in searching uh there's a few apps
that we actually created in this movie
too that could exist in real life but
citizen which one Patrol where you see
Kevin that the whole thing with Kevin
happened was inspired by the app citizen
which uh I don't think existed when
searching
happened and a lot of other things like
the dating app sequence I would say is
like wouldn't have been impossible in
2018 but you might have been a little
more skeptical whereas now it's like oh
yeah totally
that's awesome yeah I I love these
movies because I find myself sitting
there trying to anticipate what they're
going to go for like do this do this and
then I feel so proud of myself when they
like when they go and do what I thought
they were gonna do
um do you feel like these films have any
commentary on how much we're on our
devices or you weren't really going that
direction
I think they have some commentary on
what our devices are doing to us I I
don't know if how much time we spend on
them
um but but I think overall I mean you
know Nick tell me what you have to add
to this but like I think overall we're
trying to not think of it as a good or a
bad like force and just think of it more
as a setting and a place for a story to
unfold really
yeah I I would I will will
um likes to say it's it's more like
technology is more of like a force
multiplier here right so there's a lot
of bad and good things happening
technology is a is a I guess a conduit
in some sense
um and and obviously there's a lot of
commentary on True Crime and we were
kind of one of the uh fun things about
making a movie like this is it takes so
long to make that we were seeing True
Crime cases happening in real time and
seeing things that kind of bothered us
by like victim blaming and and
um you know these uh people making
theories that are wildly
um irresponsible and we were able to
kind of feed that in uh to the movie as
we were going so there is some
commentary that's wild because you're
right if you watched everything that has
come on about the Idaho murders you
could draw a lot of parallels to this
film
um because everything is so
out there in and there's like a true
crime Twitter and like True Crime Tick
Tock and everybody contributing not very
helpful it's like arrest the librarian I
know she did it
um is have you ever thought of applying
the formula of these films to different
genres like sci-fi or horror
or a rom-com well I mean the truth is
like for searching which is a movie that
we made before this it actually started
as a prompt that we were given which was
it was for Anish and I can you make a
eight minute short film that takes place
on a computer and that was the initial
prompt we had and he had this genius
idea which is what do you typically use
your computer for like obviously use it
to connect with people you know use it
for video games but really use it for
information right you want to like learn
something or like be informed about the
news or hear about a next you know
update on your emails and the idea Niche
I was like well if it's information then
the genre should be a mystery so that
instead of having action set pieces
you're like the set pieces are a reveal
like you're saying like the audience
realizing we're about to learn something
so for us like you know we're not
necessarily the computer movie people we
we we see ourselves more as like
Thriller people or elevated people and
this is one way we can we can tell those
stories you know after all the these
long years can I congratulate you on how
genius the idea is of all the computer
screen movies to ideas to do a missing
person story it's perfect right we did
it and we did it again
um
so uh I mean I guess the next question
that naturally follows from that is
are you gonna make another
are you gonna make another computers do
you have another computer Anish and I
are gonna edit it yeah we're all
switching chairs again and Madeline
Ellie and I will learn how to use After
Effects so Natalie what did you learn
from producing missing that that led you
to be a better uh editor on on the third
one foreign
pretty amazing actually if you guys did
that
uh okay so when does this come out in
the world
uh Friday
January 20. this Friday uh tell your
friends tell your neighbors go see it
again
um what's next for all of you
besides writing another movie like
even bigger and better things
and together
well we we just wrote our next movie
that um when I say we just I mean over
the past three years we just finished
that initial direct we will produce
maybe we'll get these guys are big shots
they may not say yes to us
and this one is a heist movie Set
against the backdrop of U.S immigration
so
it takes place on a
yeah
all shot on an iPhone yeah
for you you're just waiting for their
phone call
yeah you know we'll just do whatever
yeah
well thank you so much for coming out
tonight I love these movies so much I
hate to group them into movies but I do
love searching so much too and this one
I enjoyed so much as well so thank you
for coming out and talking about it
thanks for having us thank you thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]